let's hear now from sanji javit well
since we learned about omicron our
strategy has been to buy time time to
assess it but also to build our defenses
and by far and away the best way to
build our defenses remains our booster
program and it's great to see so many
people coming forward we've now over 29
million people across the country
boosted over half of adults and hitting
new records every day but we do need
more people to come forward and keep
building the defenses for themselves for
their loved ones and for their community
but where today's announcement is about
further building those defenses by the
contracts that i've signed today which
are for four and a quarter million
additional doses of antivirals these are
special drugs that have been developed
specifically for covid they're
particularly valuable to those that are
vulnerable to covert than others those
that are immuno-suppressed it will
certainly help to keep lots of people
out of hospital and this four and a
quarter million additional doses on top
of the 730 000 we'd already purchased so
almost 5 million doses now and and
that's fantastic uh defense and and also
uh to for those people that may be
listening that are over the age of 50 or
are particularly vulnerable to covid
that test positive they can sign up to a
national study to try and access uh
these antivirals and that they can find
more details on panoramic trial dot org
do you think they'll play a significant
role in in not having to resort to
lockdowns these amplifiers i think these
are these antivirus are significant new
defenses of course we haven't had these
uh before the
the one of these anti-virals that's
already been approved by our regulator
was it was quite recent and so it's the
first time we've got this type of
defense as well but when you add this
alongside the what are called the
monoclonal antibodies that i saw here uh
being offered to to patients that were
vulnerable here at st george's hospital
alongside the booster program these
pharmaceutical defenses you're taken
together are a huge new way to defend
ourselves against kovid thank you and on
the new uh guidance surrounding
self-isolation um it's quite clear that
after seven days the advice is that
people should avoid poorly ventilated
spaces they're advised to work from home
what does that mean for care home
workers can they go back to work after
seven days you know they'll be coming
into contact with vulnerable people what
does it mean for them
these new self-isolation rules so uh the
people that are self-isolating as long
as they test negative through a lateral
flow test on day six and day seven taken
24 hours apart they can leave isolation
if you are someone that works in a care
home or the nhs even you can return to
work but of course those people will
also be following the rules that are set
by their workplaces where they test
regularly so i know that for hospital
staff that means that they will be asked
to continue to test on those other three
days as well
um
how does this cut the self-isolation
rules help the economy um when you know
clearly the recommendation is that
people spend three days after that um
seven days until isolation working from
home does it does it does it help in
that capacity well the working from home
uh recommendation is there anyway if you
can work from home if not everyone can
for those that can that's that's
something that's clearly there is
government guidance already whether you
are self-isolating or not
um we're expecting more data of course
on on mcconnell it's uh severity are you
optimistic about that data and when can
we see it when do you expect it to be
really we're learning about omicron all
the time we know that it's significantly
more transmissible
than the delta variant we know that two
doses of vaccine aren't quite enough to
help you but three doses are so please
come forward if you haven't already but
in terms of severity there is analysis
taking place that analysis isn't
complete but i do look forward to
receiving it
um
you've reportedly lost the argument in
cabinet about new restrictions uh over
christmas uh in light of the actions
taken by the
governments in wales and scotland do you
think the data might justify
new restrictions we keep the data under
review at all times it is fast changing
the situation uh there is more data not
just here from home but from abroad we
we keep an eye on all that data and and
discuss it with our expert advisors and
as the prime minister has said whilst
there's no need for any further
restrictions before christmas we will
certainly keep the situation under
review just one more if i can um you
know of course yesterday the pm said
what he said about christmas
restrictions but now the attention is
turning to new year and what should
people do at new year how should people
plan their lives for the start of 2022
you know when will they get that
certainty look
this is an uncertain time i think
everyone can see why this new variant
has come along and uh i think it's right
that we are all responding to it in the
best way that we can the government has
issued guidance there's been the plan b
that's been brought into place but we'll
keep it under review but the best advice
to everyone is you'll continue to remain
cautious and uh and and and keep looking
forward to christmas and as the prime
minister said no new restrictions uh
before christmas and and and beyond that
we will just keep the situation review
can i speak in one more um where is the
prime minister is he hiding
the prime minister he couldn't be
working harder than he is i mean i'm
having meetings with him probably two or
three times a day and i know he's taking
many other meetings focus on so many
other challenges that the country faces